il en faudrait énormément mais j
réfléchi j'ai une
rép à faire
la prière h à
faireve non par que quand il est venu
chez moi la première fois il a présenté
son filmun telle façon qu'il m'a fait
rire
présentécouphumour je suis on peut pas
avoir de l'humour comme ça et ma et
faire un mauvais film c'est pas possible
est-ce que vous aviez déjà vu des films
de non je n'avais jamais vu de film de
j'en avais entendu parler et je savais
qu'il avait fait avecavour le com les
dragueurs
Dr et je n'ai jamais eu peur parce qu'il
me fait rire il me fait rire sur le
plateau il a une façon de de
plaisaner qui est très grçante
mais très drôle le premier film c'était
le drôle de
paroissien